I wanna be the best I'm gonna be number
one that's right Heath first ethers
first I want to be number one today
we're gonna eat like Donald Trump from
all of our meals mm-hmm for breakfast oh
wow we have an Egg McMuffin and a diet
coke with a straw and no coffee oh it's
good
how many diet cokes are we having one
with every meal what glasses of water
you just have it like get an IV bag mmm
I'll be in half of this and I wanted to
take a nap this truly is fine dining
mm-hmm no it's fine we're gonna go get
back to work and then we'll come back
and have some delicious lunch I'm
excited how are you drinking better I
hate myself
why bother drinking these sugar-free
beverage if you're just gonna eat sugar
next to it how is it drop
well it's lunchtime and we had our three
cookie snack I've got it I've got two
diet cokes on my table what have we got
today for lunch
Wow two Big Macs two fish fillets remove
bread from sandwiches add lots of
ketchup eat with knife and fork or Pizza
scrape all toppings off and only eat
that eat with knife and fork
no no you heywhy get a big bag if you
take the bread away that's kind of the
special part of the Big Mac I'm digging
that lettuce back No Oh God
oh look at how he gooped out all the
ketchup and a little dollar it's cute
when it's aggressive this is not a meal
beautiful treat now you're taking the
bread away oh this is how babies eat
this is what babies ate this is how
babies eat babies eat ketchup and they
eat frozen food that's been baked do we
have any more edge of my blade you want
more ketchup no I'm [ __ ] hungry okay
like I'm sorry for being like very
aggressive right now this woman I need
I'm not full you hate killing my friends
a little bit when you bring some more
delicious food by water you want some
deck oh no it's another one game and I
still have all of these
Felisha he's doing
feel like garbage I've got a headache
can't have any more Diet Coke I'm gonna
die
what I really desperately need some
water I look at just how many won't
disturb the water
thank you
[Music]
it's dinnertime it's dinnertime
[Music]
well-done steak with terrines of gravy
bacon crumble salad to be slathered with
Roquefort dressing at my ranch [ __ ] I'm
also a ranch [ __ ]
I haven't had a well-done steak in over
a decade
how much sauce does this guy ingest
you've turned my plate in a gravy boat
his mistake might be floating at this
point there's so much baby this is like
a decent meal at my auntie's house
you're on Keith's house auntie Oh gonna
be my aunt Keith's house it landed me on
key extra I mean the steak is actually
wedding then oh god oh god this is not
bad to it are you quite nice thanks I'm
starving
okay he'll [ __ ] yeah the dessert is
chocolate cream pie and add two scoops
of ice cream just dump it out just dump
the ball just yeah pour more liquid on
my food are you I'm gonna go be in ten
daddy if you don't even see me take one
sip I don't know anything why do you
mean
I'm pretending this is wine what a time
we had big big bowl like know what I
always say go home have a bowl of water
drink some water
I've like a Gayle fool be in the
mornings that was the next time I we eat
like a world leader I just wanted to let
you know that last night at about 1:30 I
had severe stomach pains and then
proceeded to fully [ __ ] my brain it's
okay I just wanted you to know I hope
we're still friends we are it's cool
it's still it's not the worst thing I
put in my body here
[Applause]
[Music]